Hey the start of the summer anime season is pretty soon
I should probably get my ass into gear and start watching some of these shows in case I want to make a video
FFFFFFFFFFFFFFFF
Hey, there. Are you an anime watcher who's severely behind on seasonal anime and have no idea what's even going on? Well, what a coincidence?
Me too. Well, what a coincidence?
So what better way to rectify that then with some first impressions that you definitely won't care about now
That you'll definitely care about now. Even though we're already like halfway through the season
Let's start off with a slice-of-life about centaurs. So my biggest problem nowadays
When seeing these monster girl shows is that I just get too many unanswered questions about the world of these monster girls
How is a centaur wearing trousers, like how does she actually put it on. I can't see how she would reach back there
or have the dexterity with her legs to do so.
Or is it even neccessary?
Would it be public indecency if she didn't?  Does this answer the age-old question of how dogs would wear trousers?
Why do mermaids have gaps so they could wear bikinis? Did they evolve these gaps just so they could wear bikinis?
Is there a mermaid based economy just for...
bikinis? See, this is the problem these are the questions that keep me up at night. This is...
this...this is
I'm sorry, what was I talking about?
*Grunting*
*Shuffling*
*Drinking Water*
*Coughing*
WHAT
So a lot of people sent me this show jokingly thinking
I'd find some kind of enjoyment out of it.."anime is trash and so am I", am I right? HAHAHAHAHA
Okay no, just stop. I am offended if you think this show is worth my time
It is just bad...may I remind you that it is summer
2017? We live in a post Eromanga Sensei world.The entire landscape of the trash genre has
changed and will never be the same again. And this show comes along with its tesco value prison school cast and
thinks it can stand toe to toe? Imitation is the sincerest form of flattery,
but when you are trying to match the Citizen Kane of dick jokes
out-do the magnum opus of garbage you better have something special and Miss
Cocktease Cyndi, sunbed Sally and back pain Jane are nothing even close to comparison
So you know what this is just bad just scenes of try hard pandering with absolutely no innovation whatsoever
I mean really what reason could you give me to watch a show like this?
Why would I go out of my way to watch this?
Wait, what do you mean the uncensored version's already out? All right, let's just move on from now. What's uh what's what's this all about?
FUCK!!!
FUCK MAN! Gamers is the show about gamers
actual real gamers like
mobile...
Gamers..but no, it's actually legit because see? This is straight-up Blazeblue and see? This is straight-up
not counter-strike at least it better not be fucking counter-strike because what the fuck is this back-alley method
they're using to play it. It also bothers me a bit when I see the main character because it's almost as if the thought process
For his designed was something along the lines of okay
how do we design the most bland relatable protagonist possible that viewers can easily project themselves on...wait a
minute speaking of games now. I didn't watch new game
The second season here is not called "new game 2" "new game season 2" or anything else. It's just new game exclamation point exclamation
point
Why is this not called new game+??Ooo it's a new fate and these look like some sick ass action scenes, hey this might actually be
interesting, let's see what this is all about
Alright, so this is a new saber. Oh okay? So there are two Sabers. I guess oh and I guess that's a master
now that's a master, now that's, that's, uh they're all masters, wait wait.
There's 14 masters, and wait wait. Ok so there's  14 masters and 14 servants so holy shit.
That's like 28 characters and Joan of Arc and homunculi. How am I supposed to keep up with all these characters?alright
well if there are too many characters to pay attention to I guess I'll just have to do the next best thing and find best girl
and well Saber of the red and Joan of Arc are just like an inferior saber anyway, but I think I found a keeper guys *ha ha ha*
Oh that's...she uh...that's a guy isn't it?
I'm just kidding it's
2017! Of course it's acceptable to like androgynous looking anime boys
And I think now is the perfect time to settle that age-old debate of if traps are gay or not. 'cause I have the definite answer
are
traps gay?
No traps are not gay...
they're homosexual.
Hey, look, it's "Free!" except less gay and sets with jolty looking dive animation. Hey, look it's "Yuri!!! On Ice"
except less gay, and it sets on land with jolty looking necks. Hey look it's "Yuri!!! On Ice" except there's no ice and it's just straight-up yuri.
So far the show has achieved more hot and steamy relationship progression within two minutes than most anime achieve within 24 episodes
I mean this chick seems thirsty enough to drink the Amazon River dry
But what can I expect from a show literally abbreviated to NTR? Let's see...
There's two girls cheating on their respective
Boyfriends with each other and abusive jock and of course the good old innocent Cuck Norris judging from the first episode this has the potential
to end in "School Days" level of relationships fuckery
But I will say if the show doesn't end in more scissoring than "Kill La Kill" then I will be very disappointed
You know what I'm going back to this. "Welcome to the ballroom" isn't just yuri on land starring well-dressed giraffes
It's a genuinely entertaining show about a boy finding his true passion.
It's one of my favorites of the season so far
And I highly recommend you give it a watch because apparently no one else is. Of course it wouldn't be a proper anime season without
An Isekai show in it. See, for those who don't know Isekai means "another world". It has become a genre
I'm sure many of you are aware of because we need about 10 million fucking new ones every season now. Used to be hey look
It's just another guy transported to a fantasy world, but now they're just straight up putting Isekai
in the title of these shows. I mean just look at nights and Magic where if you literally just cut out the first two minutes
of the show you'd have no idea it was even an Isekai show
Why is this an Isekai show? Look I get it the guy was a gunpla nerd who was also a programmer and that's
Why he's able to design and program these otherworldly robots so well
But couldn't you have just made the story about the character being a super skilled engineer instead of being like..."this guy can do
anything because no one here even knows how to printf "hello world" and their primitive technology still codes everything as minions"
But I'm not done yet. See it's a guy transported to a fantasy world anime, but this time he has a smartphone
A SMARTPHONE! Is this really how much we're scraping the barrel for Isekai shows? What happened to fantasy anime that you know...
Were just fantasy anime?
The best first episode of this season
Undoubtedly went to "Made in Abyss" that immediately grabs my attention with its amazing atmosphere and world building
There's an unbelievable sense of adventure that instantly seizes your curiosity not by explaining anything but by dropping you knee-deep into this world
Why are there chibi Explorers? What's this massive worm monster that is flying about, that's NOT IN CG!
Why are there robots in the world?
Where are we even? What's that massive hole? It gave me the same feeling as when I first
booted up "Breath of the Wild" I wanted to find out more and explore the world out of genuine curiosity and just as that
curiosity is piqued you're giving your first bit of
exposition or dialogue at the very end of the episode that just leaves you wanting to explore more. This is how to start up a
fantasy world, and I can't tell you how big my boner was during this opening sequence with the fantastic visuals
and brilliant insert song and Ufotable back at it again with a beautiful-looking adaptation
No one gives a shit about because the source material isn't affiliated with any types of moons. Kakegurui is a show about
gambling starring a bunch of crazy-ass fucking chicks who get hot and bothered when they're betting
But as cool as that is you know a wise man once said long ago. Do not stick your dick in crazy
Fuck that guy. Today I offer you some new words of wisdom. "You can't spell psycHOTic without hot
Damn, is this really worth my penis? Honestly though
What more can you ask for than an addictive gambling show where the girls are really really really
enthusiastic about gambling like Super Enthusiastic like extremely enthusiastic like so enthusiastic
I'm wet enough to shove this gun up my
hey not to be that guy
But I made the right fucking call when I gave a shout-out to the manga a few months ago so if you
do you want to read the head in the manga
You can do so at Book Walker in the description below and you can also use coupon code Gigguk for five dollars off
But you know that thing I actually can't wait for the most is that
Ova one shot where the cast traveled to Vegas for a night that we're totally going to crowd fund into production now
For a Hentai Haven Original. "Aho Girl" is a tragic show
But I'm glad it exists there needs to be more shows
Highlighting mental disabilities and the struggles that these people can go through from physical abuse
Neglecting parents and arduous battles with their addiction to bananas and its just tragic to see people looking at this and just
laughing....oh
oh okay
Um apologies! Apparently it's not about mental disabilities
It's just a guy who really doesn't want to stick his dick in stupid
You know the season has been a bit quiet within the community with some of the best shows being behind services
I can't get behind but at least we still got "My Hero Academia" to keep us company
And I think this is a good time to bring this up.Look, the tournament arc in "My Hero Academia" was amazing
But it's over now I've made my whole video about it
So I think this is a good time to kill off the tournament arc meme. You know...
I love my tournament arcs and will continue to love my tournament arcs
but constantly shouting it out is getting tiring. So let's just move on now. There's nothing more to get excited about anymore wait...
is...this a
TRAINING ARC!!!!!!!!!!!
Hey guys, hope you enjoyed that video. Thank you very much this month to...Hadrel Leon, Basel
Lee Watts, Thrones Melt and everyone else on Patreon for supporting this month and making this video possible.
Again if you do want to read ahead in Kakegurui
Officially, you can do so in the link below from Book Walker and use coupon codes Gigguk for five dollars off. Also I haven't officially announced
this on this channel yet
But I will be guesting at Crunchyroll Expo in just under two weeks in Santa Clara from August 25th to August 27
So if any of you are going, I hope to see you there once I get a more detailed schedule
What I'll be doing off put another video up anyway, that's it for me for now
I've been Gigguk and I'll see you all next time